i have a great clip today of pete but
edge edge just crushing a
mayonnaise-brained fox news host who
tries to do
the same old thing to mayor pete who is
now secretary of transportation pete
buddha judge so here's the the kind of
setup
as many of you know
or may have heard
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh
recently
had to deal with protesters at a
restaurant
and in the aftermath of this and brett
kavanaugh leaving through the back door
people started talking about the right
to have dinner at restaurants and the
right to privacy and all of these crazy
things in the context of what's
happening with abortion laws and the
fact that there have been uh protests at
uh abortion clinics family planning
clinics that that provide abortion
services for so long and they are
intimidatory and and predatory against
women who just want to go and get
procedures done there it's a medical
location the contrast is unbelievable
truly
and in the midst of this
a pete buddha judge's husband put out a
tweet talking about oh you know right to
privacy and kind of poking fun at the
absurdity and the double standard of
these right-wingers so mayor pete goes
on fox news and the host tries to pull
the whole is it appropriate for the
husband of a you know
and pete buttajedge puts on a clinic
truly excellent we've talked about his
skills before
it's hard to find a time where he goes
on fox news and doesn't humiliate the
host and the entire apparatus of fox
news so let's just jump into it and
we'll talk about it as we watch it your
husband tweeted after
uh justice brett kavanaugh left a
washington restaurant
due to protesters the tweet reads sounds
like he just wanted some privacy to make
his own dining decisions
is that appropriate
sir look when uh public officials go
into public life we should expect two
things one you should always be free
from violence harassment and
intimidation and two you're never going
to be free from criticism or peaceful
protest people exercising their first
amendment rights and that's what
happened in this case remember the
justice never even came into contact
with these protesters reportedly that's
an important thing he did he became
aware that they were out front and he
left through the back door see or hear
them
and these protesters are upset because a
right an important right that the
majority of americans support was taken
away and not only the right to choose by
the way but but this justice was part of
the process of stripping away the right
to privacy as long as i've been alive
settled vice law in the united states
and listen to the fox host trying to
interject has been that the constitution
protected a right to privacy and that
has now been thrown out the window by
justices including justice kavanaugh who
as i recall swore up and down
in front of god and everyone including
the united states congress that they
were going to leave settled case law
alone so yes people are upset they're
going to exercise their first amendment
rights and as long as that's peaceful
that's protected compare that for
example
to the reality that as a country right
now we're reckoning with the fact that a
mob summoned by the former president all
right well let me follow him
don't make that don't don't go into that
direction pete please united states
capital for the purpose of overthrowing
the election and very nearly succeeded
in preventing the peaceful transfer of
power but i think common sense can tell
the difference but as a high-profile
public figure sir what's funny is pete
spent 90 seconds explaining why the
question is ridiculous
and the host just basically repeats the
question are you comfortable with
protesters
protesting when you and your husband go
to dinner at a restaurant
protesting peacefully outside in a
public space sure look i can't even tell
you the number of spaces venues and
scenarios where i've been protested and
the bottom line is this any public
figure should always always be free from
violence intimidation and harassment but
should never be free from criticism or
people exercising their first amendment
rights pete buddha judge is really
really good at this and these are the
types of things where
these
this plays well you know tens of
millions of views in the kind of online
sphere youtube and twitter etc
uh but the bigger issue is lots of
people are never exposed to these types
of confrontations of the absurdity of
the arguments they're making
it's okay to protest outside an abortion
clinic where women are making medical
decisions and receiving treatment and
and grappling with difficult decisions
but morton's steakhouse out front while
kavanaugh's inside and doesn't even come
into contact with the protesters we're
so supposed to believe that that is
in some way unacceptable and with all of
these these things
all of the tone policing and decorum
there are major double standards we
talked about one earlier on in the show
barack obama was regularly criticized
for these little tiny meaningless things
oh he took off his suit jacket in the
oval office he wore a tan suit at a
serious event he put his feet up on the
desk at the white house and trump drops
an f-bomb while attacking his political
opponents at his rally in anchorage over
the weekend and it's not just that the
crowd doesn't mind they cheer they
celebrate the fact that trump is
swearing
by their logic very unbecoming of a
former president so
uh a lot of people i know are saying
well david what if this happened to you
this has happened to me i mean i i there
have been people
at events that i've done
who were in the room and this was a
while ago and they stood up and they
stood they tried to kind of take over
the event by asking these attack sort of
questions uh to the point where the
organizers said hey guy okay we're that
that's good you've made your point we're
now moving on at a restaurant i believe
it was last summer i told the story of
an anti-semitic confrontation and it was
not someone coming up to me and saying
hey you know david i know your show and
i disagree with you about your take on
the israeli-palestinian conflict and i'd
love to talk to you about my perspective
that that would be fine let me have my
dinner and then we can talk about that
no it was a screaming imperialist jew
bastard at me from across the room uh
while i'm with my friends having dinner
and hey you know what it's not
comfortable but what is the argument
that it's illegal or what exactly is it
that they are saying oh well it's the
appropriateness of the husband of the
secretary of transportation supporting
protesters who kavanaugh never even came
in to cut come on guys give me a break
and so pete doing an excellent job
he would be
again we're i'm talking here about
optics and skill
he would be a very reasonable
presidential candidate
now more well known than he was last
time around i find him very interesting
highly skilled and he did an excellent
job there
one of our sponsors is emmy
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes amy
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
plant-based with 18 grams of fiber for
digestive health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen emmy comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp and black garlic chicken
if you try imme and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below